good morning Hank it's Tuesday in a
stirring turn of events I find myself in
an airport I'm on my way to Davos
Switzerland for the World Economic Forum
which is a gathering of like world
leaders and CEOs and Leonardo DiCaprio
and I guess me to discuss the future of
the world's economy I'm not even there
yet and I already feel a little bit out
of place but Davos Switzerland was also
the setting of one of my all-time
favorite novels the magic mountain by
Thomas Mann so while I'm there I get to
do a bit of literary tourism which as
you know Hank is one of my three
favorite hobbies my favorite hobby is of
course being eating pizza sponsoring
fourth tier soccer teams and literary
tourism anyway Hank you can follow my
trip to Davos on my Twitter or Instagram
or snapchat I don't actually know how to
log on to my snapchat but I'm gonna try
to figure it out
all of that however is an aside because
it's Tuesday it's question Tuesday the
day that I answer real questions from
real nerdfighters let's belatedly get
right to it
how's the writing going I think it's
going well I'm sorry it's taking so long
what's gonna be the title of your new
book I don't know you got any ideas I'm
definitely in the market for a good
title so if you have one leave it in
comments what is your opinion of inside
jokes yeah yeah who are you gonna vote
for for president oh no no no no no I am
not paying attention to the so-called
presidential election until 100 days
before the primary in my home state of
Indiana which means that I have a few
more blessed days not to think about it
and I am going to enjoy them will you be
my friend even though I'm a Slytherin
yeah sure hufflepuffs are kind and
caring and open unlike some people I
know can you six degrees of Kevin Bacon
yourself yeah I acted in The Fault in
Our Stars movie admittedly my scene was
cut but it was in the extended version I
acted with Laura Dern who was in
novocaine with Kevin Bacon how should a
dog wear pants when it comes to dogs
with pants I stand with the president at
this point do presidential debates
actually accomplish what they're
supposed to accomplish well so far as I
can tell at this point what they're
supposed to accomplish is selling lots
of extra expensive advertising on cable
news networks in which case yeah they're
very effective how do you think the
world will end well I've got a list of
my top ten eschatological anxieties but
in the end I'm with TS Eliot on this one
not with a bang but with a whimper
what is Looking for Alaska going to be
made into a movie oh I don't know maybe
never
I sold the movie rights to a movie
studio more than ten years ago and I
have tried many men
many times to buy them back in the
intervening decade but thus far that
hasn't happened they've tried to make a
movie a bunch of times but it's always
falling apart for one reason or another
and at this point I'm not involved in
the project in any way I'm not gonna lie
it definitely bums me out but it also
reminds me just how lucky I was to have
two amazing book-to-movie experiences
the truth is authors are almost never as
welcomed into the process as I was with
The Fault in Our Stars in Paper Towns so
I tried just to be grateful for that
so if you don't you're looking for
Alaska movie updates for me that's why
maybe that will change someday I hope so
but I don't expect so any plans to come
back to crash course yes this summer
we're going to do another miniseries of
crash course literature we're going to
read Huckleberry Finn an Invisible Man
and a hundred years of solitude in their
eyes we're watching God and some
Shakespearean sonnets it's going to be
amazing
who's your celebrity crush right now I
definitely say lin-manuel miranda is
there a smell that's important to you
and brings you back to a particular time
in your life yeah there's an odor of
like spray smell called spring rain that
brings me back to high school because
it's what my roommate and I always use
to cover up the smell of cigarette smoke
obviously don't smoke it's a tremendous
waste of time and money but that spring
rain odor brings me right back to high
school it's like this horrific horrific
scent but it only makes me feel happy
all right I got to go board the plane
next week I'll give you some thoughts
from doughboys in the meantime I will
see you on Friday